hi I'm date Mike nice to meet me how do
you like your eggs in the morning
let's face it most guys are from the
Dark Ages they're cavemen and they like
a woman to be showing her cleavage and
to be wearing eight inch heels and to be
wearing
um see-through
Underpants
but
for me
a woman looks best when she is just
absolutely naked
hmm
um
you don't want anything my treat
some panties or
got thong or g-string
tea back
get a nice bra
padded bra
see-through push up Lace thigh high
bustier anything it just you know what I
would love
to buy you a fresh set of underwear okay
Wendy
hot and juicy redhead
give this a try
Wendy's hello Wendy this is Kevin's
friend Michael
this isn't Wendy oh I'm sorry could you
put her on please dude this is a Wendy's
restaurant
okay
um
could I just have a Frosty and baked
potato please
well send somebody to pick it up just
have it ready ready now
well I'll put it aside
oh
I thought something would
think would happen so like
so alike
what are you doing what are you doing
yes I didn't
have a ride home
this one is handed all right girls bring
it up you're being infiltrated in
the hen house Cox in the hen house don't
say Cox no
uh what is your name Affair Lass
Katie ah Katie wow look at you you are
uh you're like the new and improved pam
pam 6.0
oh look oh hey no cat fights you two I'm
against violence in the workplace oh my
and nobody cares who you think it
doesn't matter
you know what
I love Phyllis
you know what else
I think she is gorgeous I think she is
an incredibly incredibly attractive
person
you know what the only thing I am
worried about
I'm getting a boner
good work today everybody
thank you very much
our suspect has straight brown hair
she is wearing blue jeans and a black
top
so
Behold our Bachelorette
give her a 10 for looks and a three for
her ability to describe herself
hello my lady
Michael
ah
are you Michael Scott
so Michael what
oh I'm sorry I'm I'm supposed to be
meeting someone named Michael oh that's
not yeah Michael
Michael
large hot chocolate with caramel and
shot of peppermint
hey guys guys
ready
what are you doing I'm trying to not
understand with my top likely not to do
this
oh yeah
oh wow that was close I would say I kind
of have an unfair Advantage because I
watch reality dating shows like Hawk and
I learn I absorb information from the
strategies of the winners and the losers
actually I probably learned more from
the losers
foreign
I have recently taken a lover well
that's great congratulations
who's the lucky lady Pam's mom
what Pam's mom Helene remember from your
wedding
you're messing with me but what you did
not have sex with Pam's mom oh big time
what kind of cars to drive she drives a
green camera and the seats go all the
way down
all the way down oh my God
um times have changed a little
and even though we're still a family
here at Dunder Mifflin families grow
and at some point the daddy can't take a
bath with the kids anymore
I am upper management and it would be
inappropriate for me to take a bath with
Pam as much as I might want to
he said what
I live by one rule
no office romances no way very messy
inappropriate
no
but
I live by another role
just do it
Nike
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office somebody who I
think a lot of us cannot keep
checking out
the hottest in the office award goes to
Ryan the champion
[Applause]
[Music]
what am I gonna do with the award
laughs
nothing I I don't know what I'm gonna do
that's the least of my concerns right
now I hear them kissing all the time
it's this horrible pooping sound no it's
like Chinese Water torches
like it's coming from my own head
that's it
Just Close Your Eyes
can you get lower oh yeah a little lower
I cannot keep myself from Michael
everything he does is sexy he has this
undeniable animal magnetism he's a
jungle cat
the man exudes sex he can put both his
legs behind his head
wait we'd like to enter into the record
of Paige from Michael Scott's personal
Journal whoa whoa whoa whoa what do you
do with my diary this is plaintiff's
exhibit 107. I quote from an entry dated
January 4 of this past year
just got back from Jamaica
tan almost everywhere Jan almost
everywhere he he oh diary what a week I
had sex with my boss I don't know if
it's going to go anywhere Jan was very
specific that this is not going anywhere
that it was a one-time mistake but we
had sex six times so you tell me I am
definitely feeling very eerie
irie sorry more tomorrow XOXO Michael